For McDonald's, the Big Mac once had the mouths of millions of young people...
...watering with anticipation.
But millennials don't have as big of an appetite...
...for the fast food chain's flagship product.
In July, a top McDonald's franchisee sent an internal memo...
...to fellow operators, saying that the Big Mac had gotten "less relevant."
Just one in five millennials has even tried a Big Mac, the memo said.
The number of hamburgers sold at McDonalds US restaurants has been flat...
...for the past few years and grew at an annual rate of just one percent to two percent before that...
...according to former high-ranking McDonald's executives.
The Wall Street Journal Julie Jargon reports...
that competing restaurant chains are pulling in customers...
...by offering gourmet made-to-order burgers and quick casual service.
That's at odds with McDonald's sales strategy for the last six decades,...
...which is focused on speed and low cost.